[Music]
no matter where they'd come from many
had a tale of disrupted travel
most trains across the uk were cancelled
leaving some southampton supporters to
travel the 150 miles north to leicester
themselves
i've got a six and a half hour drive
when i've got to sit on a train quite
nicely read the paper out of sleep
it's uh it's been a nuisance yes i do
feel sympathy for them however there's
got to be another way because the
disruption is phenomenal all over the
country means you can't get anywhere
we travel over on the peterborough line
which stops off stanford okay melton all
the all the boys come over here and do
that and to be honest with you
that train is full all the time every
game every week and
so we've all had to drive so
one out of the four has had to go a
little bit dry today unfortunately
thousands of fans here and elsewhere
won't be able to get a train home either
it is the last scheduled rail strike
that we know about but so bitter is the
dispute it is unlikely to be the last
[Music]
this is the seventh walkout of the
summer with railway workers demanding
job security better working conditions
and a pay rise in line with the cost of
living but there's impasse between the
westminster government and the unions
who say the transport secretary is
refusing to get involved in negotiations
well we'll keep going our members are
very committed to the dispute we'll keep
going until we get in an agreement that
our members support and then they'll get
to vote on what's on offer once we get a
reasonable package so we are committed
to this dispute we've got no choice
because we're under attack
from the companies and from the
government
transport secretary grant shaps tweeted
i've written to mick lynch to urge him
to put network rails fair eight percent
pay rise offer to his members
rmt is prolonging these unnecessary
strikes which are a kick in the teeth to
workers who cannot get to their own jobs
while many commuters worked from home
this week
if you want to get to a festival you
have to travel
we definitely cannot afford to stay
until the end of the show because there
is no chance to get home where we live
and
it would get
very expensive i'm glad that people have
the chance to make that point
but of course it's our suffering and not
the guy going to work in their limos and
black cups not really that far if we
were to share an uber it would be
not that expensive each so wires come to
worse we'll be ubering home but they
will know that no one can get home so
they will try to purchase that yeah
we'll just have to deal with that
it was supposed to be the summer where
everything got back to normal but right
now the vibe is far from feel good
lisa dowd sky news